la realidad de israelí más violenta de
cisjordania ocupada en 2022 se causó
cuatro muertos y 44 heridos en el campo
de refugiados de yenín El estallido se
produjo cuando comandos israelíes
rodearon la casa de dos sospechosos a
los que buscaban arrestar por participar
y planear ataques y luego de una
explosión comenzaron los tiroteos el
ejército israelí ha identificado a uno
de los cuatro fallecidos como Abel
fatijasem hermano del hombre que mató en
abril a tres israelíes en un ataque en
tel aviv Aunque en total tres de los
muertos pertenecían a las brigadas
galaxsa y uno era un agente de
inteligencia de la autoridad Palestina
así de nuevo la violencia causó temor en
la población civil en vídeos difundidos
por redes sociales se observa al menos
una guardería y una escuela primaria en
las que los niños estuvieron que
resguardarse de los enfrentamientos que
no quedaron solo en jenning en la
atención se extendió en albiré en las
adyacencias derramala donde unas
protestas fueron reprimidas por las
fuerzas israelíes Mientras que fatá el
partido de la base que gobierna en
cisjordania convocó a una jornada de
huelga y alertó de una peligrosa
escalada esta ya se observa en jerin y
nabús en el norte de Jordania donde
Israel lleva a cabo redadas casi a
diario en el marco de una campaña que se
llama de contra terrorismo tras una
serie de ataques en marzo y abril que
causaron la muerte de 19 israelíes el
gobierno de Israel acusa a la autoridad
Palestina de no estar haciendo lo
suficiente para frenar a las milicias
que operan en la zona mientras que desde
ramala consideran que es Israel quien
contribuye a la inestabilidad con estos
operativos que han alimentado la mayor
muerte de palestinos bajo fuego israelí
en sí jo